was ist los mit den grünen reden wir
darüber mit einer sagen wir mal art
parteienforscher mit olaf schubert
[Applaus]
was wird erklärst du den aktuellen
niedergang der grünen
da kann man nicht schönreden ich habe
die grünen sind wirklich nur noch ja sag
ich mal so für links grün versuchte
besserverdiener mit menschen die nicht
die grünen wählt man glaube ich nur wenn
man keine ahnung von politik hat aber
nicht zugehen will
und der nimbus ist verblasst nicht grün
sind nicht so farblos dahin irgendwie
die grauen von morgen also um vielleicht
mit einem kollegen sagen hier oliver
kahn früher die grünen hatten eier aber
jetzt nur noch eierstöcke also das ist
alles ohne ohne bist irgendwie kaninchen
im schlaf fällt also für mich ist es
weder fisch noch fleisch also in dem
fall weder dinkel noch zu früh zu sagen
wie gefallen die die beiden
spitzenkandidaten gefallen sind weil die
grünen ganz klar sind zwei randgruppen
kandidaten also einer mit
migrationshintergrund einem informations
und sondern eine doppelspitze das
assoziierte immer gleich sind wissen
alleine wären sie überfordert
der starke hält das heft glauben und
regen
[Applaus]
polarisierte wenigsten noch einigermaßen
aber hier die frau die die katrina
katrin göring eckardt katrin göring
eckardt wirkung die anbieter ich meine
verhältnisse da konnte selbst unsere die
kanzlerin noch als fucking betreiber
also personal ist eine spur kann woran
könnte noch liegen stehen die deutschen
plötzlich nicht mehr so auf ökologie und
umweltschutz hat der deutschen
mittlerweile in den genen also ein paar
fender deutschland in urlaub fährt nimmt
der müll mit einem meter dort weiter
trennen kann
also wenn ich irgendwie in italien
bringen
google denkt drei euro spitze ab die
waffe lag fand aber dazu brauchen wir
eben nicht mehr die grün noch ein thema
aber das team hat mich im endeffekt auch
scheiße also im moment claudia martin
schule nicht nur bei den grünen der
cloud bei allen parteien was sozusagen
ist ein geheimnis sowie eine komplette
neuverschuldung des landes nicht
räumlich also eher von das
mehr von der fläche her aber nicht nach
oben als fläche nach oben und er hat
natürlich drei sachen die von merkel hat
also brille bart im bauch jetzt war 20
jahre lang mutti geführt jetzt ist die
partner und hat er wirklich so ein
nettes im klassischen süden filter und
das hat ja was geschützt als
erstbesetzung mentalität aus und was ich
wirklich faszinierend finde
der schritt der druck natürlich ist die
menge völlig bizarr also da frage ich
mich wie macht er das wirkt er spricht
von gefühlen pro jahr
nebenwirkung von beta blocker und erst
was heißt es der sozialen gerechtigkeit
aber da sehe ich natürlich was
globalisierung gewinnt jährige peugeot
schluckt opel
die zwei ältesten automaten
funktionieren und frauen zusammen
verband also fische und belgien zusammen
was kommt heraus
das hat nichts mit dem thema zu tun aber
ich fand sehr interessant olaf schubert
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]